[Music]
hi friends welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time
very nice to meet you i'm rachel
uh so the data science hangout is an
open space for the whole data science
community
to connect and chat about data science
leadership questions you're facing
and what's going on in the world of data
science
the sessions are recorded and shared to
youtube as well as the rstudio data
science hangout site
so
you always can go back and re-watch
older sessions or find helpful resources
there too
we also have a linkedin group for the
hangout too so if you ever want to
continue
the discussion with somebody or ask
other questions there
feel free to use that as well i know a
lot of times it's just me posting in
there so
feel free to
start your own posts in that group too
last week marcos had
shared an idea of starting a show and
tell or show and share thread there
so you could maybe highlight a side
project you're working on maybe a cool
tutorial
or article you found as well
but at the the hangouts were dedicated
to creating a welcoming environment for
everybody so we love when everyone can
participate and we can hear from
everybody so there's three ways you can
ask questions today
if you haven't been here before i'll
walk you through this so you can jump in
and raise your hand on zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to
your question if you wanted me to read
it out loud or maybe you're in a loud
environment
um and then lastly we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously
uh and my colleague tyler just share
that in the chat right now
just want to reiterate we love to hear
from everybody so no matter your level
of experience or the area of work as
well
but with that i am so excited to be
joined by my co-host for today
tiger tank manager of data science at
carfax
and tiger i'd like to have you introduce
yourself and maybe tell us a little bit
about your role the company
and also something you like to do in
your free time outside of work
oh sure
thanks rachel so uh my name is tiger and
then uh
really glad to be uh part of the data
science hangout and then i've been uh
following and watching a couple of
videos
in the past they've been also very
helpful to me
and then uh so i'm currently a data
science manager at carfax we are a
company focusing on providing the uh
let's just say the data insights for
uh consumers to better own shop and then
purchase the vehicle all that and then
uh oh great i saw somebody use uh carfax
before so great and then uh so myro is
basically uh building a data science
team and then that's uh mostly focused
on nlp because we receive a lot of car
information where
we have to use a lot of the nlp
techniques to handle and then to make it
uh displayable on our product
and then we also do some of the
forecasting and then uh that's my main
team's focus and then we do
a lot of analytics here and there
uh and then for this team we have
uh so far we this is our second year
and then so
it's from uh almost one or zero to now i
think around seven to eight people uh
that number of luxuries because of the
number of interns that we have
um
yeah and then in my free time and then i
like to uh
collect shells so seashells uh if i go
to like a different beach and then i
will uh
check out
on the sand and then uh yeah
just uh you'll probably if you uh see me
you know
just uh keeping my head down for a
couple hours that's me just trying to
find shark teeth all that
usually nothing can be found but i just
enjoy uh looking for things
it reminds me of a little bit like a
data mining right but usually i think
with r uh i can i can find a little bit
more things but uh
just me walking by this end and then by
the ocean uh usually the sifter is not
as good as the r2 as i use at work
i love it
and that's why you have the blue
background there like the c
i um
i know somebody had reached out to me
earlier this week and
said that they love to learn a little
bit more about nlp use cases
and since you focus on this area i'd
love to learn a little bit more about
how you use nlp
oh sure
uh so for that uh let's just say if you
go to a
a specific uh
let's just say one example is that if
you go to uh like a service shop and
then to service your car and then you
will get an invoice of saying that this
is the stuff that uh that you have they
have performed services on
and then basically we will probably
receive like information pieces of
information similar to that invoice
layout
but then
the data content is probably maybe could
be uh just written by the technician
it could be a standardized language for
that specific location or management
system and when we get there i'll get
that and then it could really be
a million different ways
uh to say to trying to express the same
service so this is where we will try to
make a good sense of that data and
trying to understand hey rachel for your
car service let's just say last friday
what was being done there
so that once we have that information we
can display that uh on the product
so
uh
then
think most of our cases is trying to
make the sense of the
uh the human region data or that type of
card related information
and uh
and i would say the techniques you would
use is something that
could really uh differ between let's
just say if you're if we're just doing a
prototype and the initial proof of
concept you can just start by building
very simple and straightforward let's
just say uh logistic models and then uh
just to uh and there's of course uh the
julia silk i don't know how to pronounce
uh people's last name correctly but uh
uh there are books on the uh uh what is
that the tidy
models with i think there's also a with
a mill and that book
the supervised
machine learning with r and their own
tax modeling all that those are very
great resources if people are interested
in uh let's just say applying nlp
related stuff in the other work
uh but i guess the most important case
to me is to find a great uh is a oh
somebody already shared the link thanks
libby
and then uh
i think establish the business case
first is very important but then
the model uh
development can really differ just based
on the timeline that you have and the
resources you have
thanks for sharing that in the chat too
olivia i was just about to say would
someone be able to share that because
i'm bad at multitasking here and you
were right on it
appreciate it
um tiger i
i know you gave i already just posted
about this on linkedin because i loved
your r studio conference talk as well
um but i'd love to hear
a little bit more about your experience
of kind of
selling data science to the business and
getting the team on board
oh yeah uh
that that is a great question and then
uh i think it's something that
uh
i think this is also one of the uh
things that i really love about the uh
uh what's been going on recent years
about data science is that
i think let's just say take the time
back to 10 years ago and then people are
still trying to have a better definition
about data science but now
people from different back with
different background they would have
heard data science here and there so i
think makes our job easier to sell
the concept to you don't have to really
bring people up to speed on a specific
background to trying to say hey
if you haven't heard this is a great you
know data science is a great help right
but now we we got to just to be able to
focus on saying that
uh if we can utilize specific data
science tools or techniques
these are the specific business value
that we can just bring
and then so you don't have to sell the
concept of data science you just need to
sell
let's just say
specific project by project
so that's uh that's what i did in the
past is that
once i realized oh
uh if there is a uh
multiple different ways for us to
develop let's just say processes
processes reporting tools to help
business uh people account
representatives to better better manage
the account to uh to be more effective
at their jobs then i would just
use that specific business case and then
share that with upper management and
then say
uh hey guys i think i recently uh you
know identified this idea
that will as an example will help us to
speed up our roadmap
by two years uh do you want to hear
about that and but at that time
i think the one of the things i learned
is that
uh
you know at that stage you don't really
need to mention any of the tools you use
even though i am a big fan of r big fan
of shiny
and then i want to talk about it
wherever i go
but then uh
i think in the several of those
experiences when i talk about when i got
so focused on about the tools and about
the techniques
uh i guess that's uh that's turns out
that's not
everybody's focus
that's probably
people's focus when you share the same
background when you are talking to a
fellow data scientist so they're going
to get excited too so uh but in this
case uh i
just said hey this is the value
this is how much time you can save this
is how much business value that we can
accumulate
with such shorter time and then if you
allow me and i can present you a roadmap
right if you give me like one month of
doing the pilot i can even show you some
of the initial business value
so uh i never tried to persuade
people to say hey data science is
valuable
i i think showing it exactly you know
give me a week give me two weeks i'm
going to show you a proof of concept
right there and then uh they will buy in
the idea themselves
so i think so that's what have uh worked
out really well for me and i think i
also have a a very understanding uh
leadership there so uh there when they
once they see that and then i think the
buying process went very smoothly
that's great thank you and i see mark
you're commenting in the the chat can i
have you share that as well is that okay
yeah sure sorry
yeah i just said that um
some of the stuff that you talked about
in your
conference talk i've actually used um
like some of those ideas to get a
project green light basically just
starting from the value problem and
working backwards to
what i'm interested in which is like how
to do it but
you know
telling to the stakeholder like here's
why you would actually be interested in
this which
um i'm not always the best at uh
going in that direction so um
yeah glad that that that methodology
worked out
great also here
do you have any tips for how we can all
get better at at doing that
we're communicating that to the business
so i know it's like putting it in terms
of the money and return on investment
but do you have other tips for
communication
well yeah so uh uh one of the things i
uh i think my one of my phone were uh
boss and then uh did this exercise a lot
of times with me is that
uh sometimes i want to get uh
let's just say the technical details and
then so he would always say to me hey
tiger how about this explain to me like
i'm a five-year-old so that's where i'm
trying to
that's where my uh
i just turned myself into like let's
just say if this is a difficult concept
can i use very good uh analogy there
uh and then to make people understand so
when i say that
as an example if i say i want to try
explore different uh
nlp method and then this will uh you
know need uh different you know let's
just say additional resources
but when i say that hey this is a
different different deep learning method
i wanted to try
how do i show that's uh you know uh
because this is exploration phase how do
i show this additional value
then one of the well one of the analogy
i came up with i i still i'm still not
sure if it's a good analogy so i'm going
to try it and then you guys can now let
me know so i'm going to say that hey
when you have the raw data this is like
uh you're you have a uh you know uh
like i like to say right by stake right
and then this whole modeling process is
like a cooking so once you have the
let's just say logistic model a deep
learning and then let's just say the
transfer models then
these are just different ways of cooking
the same state and then let's just say
you can pan fry and then you can use
airfryer which is the newer ways and
then but we really need to
try different ways and to identify the
best way to cook this uh piece of steak
and then the hyper parameter tuning
those are just you know us too trying to
change the time of cooking turn the uh
let's just say
uh
the you know use the oven for to change
the temperature
uh of cooking right so uh that's where
suddenly all of these big words from the
uh
from those uh let's just say machine
learning methodology turn it into
something that most people can relate
right and then uh uh i think everybody
when i whenever i said that and then
people are like yeah yeah i think i know
what you're saying so uh but i just
don't know yeah uh i think analogy is
definitely a great way to uh to get
everybody
uh there and uh
and another thing is that
i would always hold and try to hold the
urge
uh of sharing any of the technical
breakthrough
uh that i really wanted to share with
everybody so one example is that um
uh
i think uh around four years ago i was
in the art studio conference and i heard
our studio folks and then talked talked
about the uh
the future
future plus promises so that you can
have make your apps async asynchronous
so that you can handle multiple uh
at the same time
i got super excited because i have
several apps that handles a lot of
requests that would have been uh
would have been uh let's say hundreds of
ticket requests to our department
uh and then this is where i was saying
oh we need to invest more time to do
this
but then i don't really have a good way
and then i was saying we can make the
app asynchronous
r
is a you know it says can only handle
single threaded jobs
people are lost
and then i was like how can you you know
uh how come this is you know i i think
everybody had a great feedback when joe
chan was talking about it how come i
can't you know get that across
and then later on i realized that it's
uh unless this is happening to people uh
downgrading people's apps experience
they shouldn't they should never need to
know or is single threaded
because it doesn't really matter so in
that case i was like uh i sense the room
is uh nobody's understanding what i'm
saying
so then i'm saying that you know what if
we do this
even if we have 10 users running those
different tasks at the same time their
experience is going to be perfect but
right now if you have them doing the
doing that i think everybody has to wait
and then the business side yeah let's do
it so i think this is the part that
still uh of course i i i was still
sharing that uh hey we're
once the promises are out where maybe uh
maybe one or two months after the talk i
heard i implemented right away so uh i
was still proud of that and i still talk
to you let's say my team member to say
hey you know what later on uh you know
our studio folks told me uh once i share
this our studio folks told us uh we're
one of the first group that implemented
this so i still feel proud it's just
that i just don't share that with my
stakeholder because i know hey fellow
data scientists they can get it so i
would say
use analogy
wherever you can of course run that by
your colleagues maybe
and then uh
the other one is hold the urge of
sharing technical breakthrough with your
stakeholder or with your maybe upper
management whoever does not have who
doesn't have this data scientist
background as you do
and maybe share that with
let's just say across
teams something like that
that's incredibly helpful thank you
i see there's a lot of anonymous
questions starting to come in as well in
slido so just a reminder people can ask
questions over there on slido too
but one was what's the difference
between a business analyst and
data scientist or data science manager
in your eyes
oh
uh
well i can only offer my uh
understanding there so
a business analyst i think
in my
company and then
they'll be more focused on
let's just say
uh
building that bridge uh between the
business side and and then some of the
analytics side
uh and then building let's just say
translating the business needs to the
development criteria that developers and
then legislative data scientists needs
to follow so i almost i think uh
business analysts they have they need to
have the
let's just say more have that business
mindset rather than the analytical
mindset so it's a mixture maybe like a
80 20 something like that
but uh if you're talking about like just
say data analysts they probably we need
to balance that a little bit more like a
50 50.
and then for my role
specifically for for my company uh we're
just uh i'm trying to develop this team
and then that have let's just say uh
data analyst uh data scientist and then
other function that related to how my
company uh utilizes data science
so i hope that helped uh clarify that
thank you
niall i see you asked a question in the
zoom chat do you want to jump in and ask
it
yeah sure so uh you talked earlier about
um bringing the ideas to the
stakeholders uh which leads me to assume
that a lot of your projects are created
within the data science team
you know your spitballing brainstorming
coming up with ideas and then sort of
selling them which is is great
um
when it works and i'm curious about your
your balance between those projects and
projects that are coming from outside
within the organization saying hey we
really want to do this and we think you
guys have the skills to help and and how
you sort of balance those and then also
the success rate of of each i guess is
where i'm really interested like are
they more likely to succeed if they're
coming in with that outside by and at
the start
or uh if they're coming in with your
knowledge of data science
gosh a question oh that's a great
question i actually uh
uh well this is something i'm still
working on
yes i'm preparing a presentation to
actually uh work uh what is that
evaluating some of those ideas for
uh business side business related data
science idea you know coming from them
instead of coming from my team
uh
so i would say that's that immediately
just making me think about uh let's just
say two things the first one is that uh
how
possible that is to achieve uh let's
just say in the realistic timeline uh
because when they
well
we we definitely you know a lot of the
ideas coming from everywhere but
sometimes we may not really get the data
to help us to come up with a let's just
say
a reliable recommendation
so this is something that i think
whenever we received this type of
request i would always ask for let's
just say one or two weeks of uh uh
either i i wouldn't really call that a
proof of concept it's even uh uh
initial investigation they're trying to
see how possible you know uh
that uh do we have all the data points
do we think this is uh this we can
provide a
viable solution to the business problem
that they are talking about
and then the next thing is if there is a
great potential then uh i will try to uh
let's just say uh
trying to see if we can uh put this on
our roadmap so this would involve like a
prioritization so
trying to say that hey how big how
important this is compared to all the
other projects that
the team is currently focusing on
so uh it so to me that's almost like
two-step if there is if everything uh
works well right uh we validate this uh
idea and we think we can offer some of
the uh viable solutions and then we
teacher size it then we send it for
let's just say stakeholders to discuss
to say this one is going to take uh
maybe half a year but we are currently
have a full roadmap do you think it's
gonna we can do that maybe next year if
not uh how about the uh you know you
guys can uh decide which one is uh more
important
but uh yeah i'm totally with you that
there is a specific uh
the success rate i never thought about
it that way but uh i never really
measured it i should say uh
but i would say
it is something i think what turned out
to be the case is that some of the ideas
that the business uh folks that
mentioned maybe two years back
and then now we suddenly realize oh we
suddenly have the data suddenly have the
tools to make it happen this is where
we're going to pitch again among the
stakeholders and then the upper
management to say
now this is possible about two years ago
uh maybe not
so i think uh yeah i i hope that uh
uh well i don't know if that answered
your question but it's uh my experience
on that so far
thanks tiger
what what was that that process for
going back to projects that were
proposed like two years ago
oh yeah so uh well
we don't really have a specific process
it's uh it's almost like uh
keeping track of all the ideas that we
want to do in the that we didn't get a
chance either the resources or we didn't
know the technology to make it happen or
you even were didn't have the data
points to make that happen
so uh in the from time to time people
will will come up with similar ideas
uh it's just that if we revisit them
at a later time maybe uh once a year for
all the past two years
ideas
i think sometimes we can
find some of the valuable information
there or even uh let's just say
uh
updated or enhanced idea like a sub idea
out of those
thank you where to track that
oh can you say that again frank yeah do
you use software to track that or or do
you does everyone just keep it in a
document and like you get together for
the annual idea hash
oh yeah i wish we have a so well we are
trying to find out better software but
usually it's just a like a document
where we have that but uh uh we use like
uh
the road map tools so the roadmap tools
will
save all the ideas where we put on
blocks
and then so once in a while we will look
at all the ideas on uh maybe block from
two years ago
and then
i think so far we've been
able to catch that through that
but i guess if we are able to set a
reminder to say let's revisit this in
two years
i think that would be great too
definitely i see there was an anonymous
question a bit earlier that was um tiger
i looked at your background and you have
an education in business school is that
a path you'd recommend to people
interested in data or more tech fields
uh
oh so for the education oh yeah yeah so
that's uh well that wasn't a really plan
to be honest the uh at that time i think
the
people are still trying to define i
think the graduate school trying to
define
uh
the data science related majors so it
just happened to be under the business
school
but of course
we have some of the business school
courses which turned out to be very
helpful
but but i think i also heard a lot of
great talks in the past on the
data science hangout i think
uh
i i don't think there is a like a
specific requirement for the people in
the let's just say have to have the
uh those type of background but i guess
you know all of these uh
i heard a lot of people uh talking about
the uh
the podcast and i i watched a uh frank's
uh episode and he also mentioned a bunch
of the great recommendations there so i
think with those
we don't really have to
let's just say go to a specific business
school to get that information i think
now it's all available online for free
so uh i almost think that uh it's a it's
a mindset that we need to all acquire i
think it's a it's important direction we
need to go but doesn't really need to
go to that specific school i would say
also love to hear that you're going back
and watching the other episodes too
frank i see you had asked a question in
the chat do you want to jump in with
that i would love to uh tiger i'm really
curious are you or your team exploring
using in any way to perform some of the
newer large language models like gbt3
that are coming out right like you do
nlp work there's some awesome advances
which pairs really well with the idea of
revisiting projects that weren't
possible before
and if not
are right do those hit your radar and
are you hopeful that you will be able to
use that in the future
oh yeah yeah uh
we are and then uh but uh this is
something that i checked with about uh i
i was planning to have like uh
because so this is the thursday uh event
right and there's another tuesday event
that people want to share like what's
going on with the work all that
someone's prepared all prepared to talk
about oh this is how we do nlp at this
company and then later on it's uh
i was told that oh these are uh this is
something that i'm not allowed to share
it's about high level i am
uh the details i cannot share but yeah
i'm super excited about those uh
and then uh uh
exploring uh those things and then uh i
think one of
the yeah uh
one of the the rest i'm gonna say is uh
i think i will receive some questions
there but uh i yeah i'm very high level
uh i'm very excited and uh this is
something that uh we're my team is
exploring
right you got to be
uh probably as excited as i am that is
september 1st and open ai is bringing
down the cost of hitting their
their api
yeah
right on
cool thank you
uh there was an anonymous question now
that was what is your relationship with
it like at your organization
oh um
yeah i i think so overall uh i'm into a
very good relationship with it
department and then while i
i think this is one that the uh amazing
thing about working at carfax in my
experience is that
they're just usually very extremely
helpful
and then i know that uh while you're
doing a lot of exploration
sometimes you run things on your
computer you'll get a lot of questions
right and then sometimes installing
things uh
but i think
well
maybe because i maintain very good
relationship uh the
i when i whenever i got a call out and
then uh it's not that serious but i i
would say uh one of the maybe uh if
you're at a much bigger you know
organization uh where you do not get to
know the whole team then uh
uh i think it would be nice to uh at
least you know explore the let's just
say
uh
maybe run it by them for some of those
uh things that you're gonna do and then
sometimes you even need to have stronger
hardware and then i think
these are the part that
i think maybe because we're like a
mid-sized company so uh knowing them
personally actually smooths my
experience so uh uh i guess if people
have uh
let's just say other experience with a
bigger company or let's say different
experience there i yeah love to hear
about those as well
but if if we are in an organization a
huge company where we don't know i.t yet
and we haven't built relationships
with them
what do you think is the best way to go
about that
oh then i would say let's not build a
relationship
just connect with them and then uh and
then say that hey here's something that
i will need to do and i will need a lot
of those things that will need adaming
rights
i think probably people uh
some of the people can relate and then
uh
uh yeah and then i just tell them this
is uh
exactly what you're gonna do and then uh
sometimes i think people is they're
going to tell you hey nobody can have
admin rights and then say uh can we have
like one day right or two hours where
you can even uh just look at my screen
or you can help me there
up to you so when you're asking for
uh smaller things people are less likely
to say no
so uh but i think my original ask was
that oh i need ammo rights to make this
work but then no
and then i was like uh can we have one
one day
uh and then uh i think the
response is much softer
so uh
that's great does your one day turn into
multiple days
yes
i hope my it friends
[Laughter]
somebody else had a question earlier was
how much time do you
explain r or any other specific language
within your organization
i'm not sure if that's
getting at like training or explaining
the languages to business users
um but it was anonymous so feel free to
add more context too in the the slido
but on that note do you
do training for
for people who are just interested in
getting started learning
yes yes i do uh
and then uh i think before i uh got my
uh
let's just say i went to the
uh
came to the us for the uh
let's just say data analytics or data
science degree i have been a teacher uh
in china
and then so i really love the the
feeling let's just say of sharing and
helping people uh
to succeed in the way
uh and then also i really enjoy teaching
and then also
this is where i think after i we gone
through the initial r training in our
organization and i began to develop the
uh
materials uh for folks and then whom i
not able to capture all the learnings in
let's just say compass two to three days
and then we have some default op
training and then later on
uh
when there's new things and then we will
just do a sharing session so as right
now we are also my team is also
preparing for
uh some of the uh recurring sharing
session uh around the company
uh
yeah and then also uh well after the our
student conference participating that
and then of course we're gonna do like a
show and tell just what you learned
so i think it is something uh would
always
uh
well if it
if we can build like a regular cadence
just like a data science hangout
similarly within the company i think
it's a great uh
growing atmosphere that we can build and
everybody and not everybody can uh well
we we only have the energy to focus on a
small part of the which is our packages
that we're interested in but then uh
if we cannot gather that together and
then it's almost like we're learning
let's say from four other people four
other people five other people are all
helping us to gather the information
so our learning speed is uh uh should be
uh
much faster
that's great and
do
do some people join those those groups
or those sessions who are just like
starting to like scratch the surface of
data science or just starting to express
interest
oh yeah so uh that is always a hard part
because people have different uh need
right so
the training will be
open to
business people who are interested in
analytics uh and then new r users
and then a data scientist a cna data
analyst all that
uh so when it comes to that and then uh
i will at the beginning of the training
i want to send out the invite i will i
would say
these are the expectations so before
this training you are expected to
complete xyz and then after the training
you will expect it to master xyz so if
you already know the answer to let's say
this next two questions no need to come
to the training or the sharing session
so we will have let's just say the
uh
beginner to intermediate session one
time into media session one time and
then an advanced session maybe a few
only a few people will show up
it's about having that having set up the
expectation
and of course always record it uh and
then uh
people then it will be helpful for
people later on so uh
this year we all my team we have several
new people joining
then uh we have them to let's just say
look at the past recordings
and then
the past handbook that we created uh
within carfax
about r
cool thank you
i see lisa you just asked a great
question in the chat do you want to jump
in
sure um i'm just um
curious and i'm sorry i did jump in a
little bit late but i did go to your
talk at our studio conference which was
awesome um so i'm just wondering like
what types of tools like analytics tools
were available to you on your first day
and then if you could like
you know i in your talk and and so far
today you've talked
maybe slightly more generically about
how to get
you know
buy-in from
whoever the people are you need buy-in
from but like was there a
specific project and i know you probably
can't talk about details but maybe like
the themes of the type of project it was
was it more like
machine learning type stuff was it more
like
i don't know shiny
reproducible reporting like what sort of
area
kind of helped you most convince people
of
the tools you needed
that makes sense yeah yeah it does it
does
lisa and then that's a great question so
i would say uh i'll just uh first answer
your the later part of the question is
that
work what really worked out uh for our
project for my project is uh uh it
starts with a shiny app because the
shiny app uh it has actually has
a shorter wrong way of developing
so uh and then after and then once well
you have the shiny app developed and uh
i think our
well this is something well i can still
make it very shareable so is that let's
just say we receive a lot of business uh
requests
and then to handle that business request
is something that you will need to have
an analyst to
look into databases
to do a lot of web requests
and then to compile those maybe in let's
just say in r in excel all that
and then share like the like the finding
for a specific uh let's just say query
and then but as more and more requests
that we're getting from them
we realize that uh it's taking a lot of
the analyst time
and then but then
the logic that we follow to get those uh
information is very similar
so then we decided to build a shiny app
and then to have all of these things
handled by shiny so then instead of
having the business folks creating a
let's just say a request
go to our internal system gets assigned
to our business analyst
or data analyst there
and then they would have to wait in the
queue right for maybe one or a day or so
maybe a couple hours then they'll spend
let's say 30 minutes to work on it now
it's going to be a click and run
for the requester
and then this whole workflow will be
gone right will be replaced by shiny so
the initial app that i think seriously
have that i developed and then just does
exactly that this is something that
allowed the allow me to say
with those three shiny apps or the first
series of shiny apps we were able to
handle i think yesterday i did the count
again
i think was
each week uh well each month now we're
still handling
560 requests that would have been
a ticket request coming to this
department
and then so with that uh well the
modeling stuff is something that you
will need a longer runway to prove the
value but for the developing of those
apps
is much shorter
and then the request that the business
need that you handle this uh is
something that would work maybe for
majority of the corporates is that we're
just saving time we're making
business requests handled faster than
before
and here's the value
and then the back to your first question
is that uh so
uh luckily i joined this company carfax
as an intern and then i moved to a
business analyst and then data scientist
and then
trying to develop a team so i started at
that time
i i think what was available to me was
excel and sas
so maybe uh uh some of the folks uh
maybe you uh using the same
at that time right
now we're all trying to move to uh
different things
so what were those steps then from going
from
excel and sas to being able to use other
tools
oh it's uh oh
this is the process that uh i think for
me i was just so excited about those new
stuff so uh i kind of forced myself to
learn things very quickly
but
we we have a whole group right at that
time i'm just one of the team member and
then when i saw oh there's a lot of
potential for people to do the same
but i couldn't really
uh it
it's difficult for you to
talk to your let's just say colleagues
uh side by side and then to say hey
there's a much better way to do it
uh
it's uh
i don't know it's not it's not really a
good way to trying to
uh
stimulate change right uh especially
when you're on the same team so i think
little what i found uh was that oh what
if
uh i can just try to automate streamline
this process and then i just show them
oh you know what uh rachel uh this one
you see you handed off me this process
uh two months ago and then used to take
i think you know half a day uh let's say
each week now uh with this uh it's just
uh
i just need to click and run
and then so and then you would it's easy
for you to see the difference it was
like i know that you have a similar task
there i cannot you know if you if you
like we can work together to get that
started
so gradually that's how i was able to
identify oh
if we could make that the streamlining
things into a project
this is how i got the work automation
project and then so
instead of trying to
do the all the training to get people to
adapt all the new things
uh
you make that whole whole mission as a
as a project
and then so people are like yeah this is
a business thing that business
initiative we're doing we're not asked
to learn new things we're just we're
asked to work on this business
initiative
throughout the process people are let's
just say
voluntarily they fall into the trap a
learning trap that is set up for them
right and then they got the excitement
of getting things working by click of a
button and then they gradually they want
to know
what's going on behind that
and then uh whenever there is error
messages they will come to me and say oh
yeah so whenever this one shows up it
means that one of the environment wasn't
set up correctly so
we're
we're not asking them to learn it from
zero to one and we're just saying
uh i'm gonna hand you off at a two you
know halfway there right and gradually
you're you're going to trying to go back
and then go forward and then trying to
uh
see the direct value there
so uh it sounds like very similar to how
we got to the stakeholder is that let me
just i'm just gonna show it to you i
don't want to
i don't need to be correct uh to
persuade you i just want to be helpful
and then this is one of the i think
having a making a business initiative
uh makes people forget about
i'm asked to learn new things all that
right so uh we kind of get past that so
uh uh yeah uh either way i think this uh
is almost like a hacking
hacky way of getting that done
thank you
yeah thank you so much
i know this is something that a lot of
people face in their organization so
sorry if i just like drive into this too
much but i'm just really curious so if
if people can't
like use the tools to begin with do they
just like
do it on the side or like they're just
like using shiny on their own desktop or
did you use shiny apps io like what do
you do first like a first step if
someone is like completely like
roadblocked by
a company
uh oh are you talking about let's just
say well you were saying like you shared
that
like a better way of doing this and now
this report that used to take half a day
is now so much quicker
oh right but i'm thinking about the
people who have told me like
i really want to do this but i can't do
it yet
do we just like go ahead and do a poc
and then show someone later
oh yeah yeah i think if i understand
that question correctly i think uh we
have to probably do a
for the initial first initial things
uh
it may be hard for for you to ask for
time or resources to say this is
something new i'm going to try i heard
every you know people outside the
company heard it's great
uh so this is where i think i spent uh
initial time at the very beginning just
as an investment
uh i guess sometimes you because at that
time i was uh
i feel the urge to uh to make it happen
so i spend some extra time to make that
initial thing work but then later on it
makes it easier and easier for you to
ask for resources in time
and that's for a
shiny app and then the initial one
is
well we don't really well there's also
the open source uh
shiny server
right so you can always use that as a
start and then to to pitch your idea
and then hosting it on your desktop it
also works so let's just say uh
one of my colleagues uh
uh he developed the legislative idea
auto evaluation
for the files that we need to look at so
if you have
uh
like a specific raw data that you need
to analyze you know the steps that you
do for the initial analyzing
is is very similar then you set up the
uh
analyzing function right after the
import just using a shiny app so with a
click of a button
you will see the uh let's just say the
analyzed uh let's just say the uh the
summary stats that you're looking for
specifically for your company for your
team
so you can just use that and run it on
your desktop and then showcase that and
then immediately
i would bet people would at least use 10
to 15 minutes to set it up all that but
if you make that automatic
just with a click of a button
it's uh it shows the value right away
and you don't need to
go through the let's just say server
setting up server all that
thank you super helpful
i see um
a few questions from earlier one was
what are the typical project timelines
given that carfax is a consumer-facing
service
i'm sure this varies but do you have an
average
uh unfortunately i don't
uh let's see another question from
earlier was
how did you actually quantify the number
of hours that you save the organization
with automation and data science
yeah that's a great one so uh you have
to so that's something that
uh i would say
at the very beginning you want to have a
clear definition of what type of time
you're counting so when you're running
uh let's just say when you're working on
analysis
so pulling data let's say from different
databases that will take time right so
if you're doing a step by step
uh it's also taking up your time to wait
for those queries those are what i would
just say is a processing time regardless
if it's a two days or one hour i don't
count those i only count the actual time
that people have to
be focused uh to interact with things
and then that's just my definition i'm
not saying uh this is a my uh
well this is what just what i do not my
recommendations specifically but once
you identify that oh it's gonna be the
manual hours that people spend then
before you apply the streamlining or
automation before
uh
you can ask the current uh report owner
process owner maybe sometimes it's
yourself ask me the number of hours you
need to spend right on a weekly daily
monthly basis first and then you
you time uh your your time yourself
again after you streamline it so you
will so what i used to have is as a
table of things these are the tasks that
we apply the automation for this is the
before uh time and then each month if
it's a daily task you use that daily it
has times 20 right whatever number of
days that you need to uh work on that
and then this is the afterwards time and
then so it's a it's a very simple uh
table that you can calculate so each
month and then you can say hey i apply
automation on the five tasks as listed
this is the total time saving the before
we need maybe 50 hours now we need two
hours in total we saved uh 48.
that's great thank you super helpful
um libby i love the question you just
put into the chat would you want to jump
in here
all right
oh there you are oh we have kitty
i'm a very needy kitty i'm sorry
everybody um i was gonna ask about
onboarding so onboarding and data
science teams can be a little bit of a
challenge for some people and i've been
through that as well as a data science
employee
um
and i was wondering if you'd found any
kind of best practices that make
onboarding a more positive experience
for everybody including like
team members that
are existing right like that can be a
burden for a new person coming in and
taking other people's time to like train
them and then get them up and going on
stuff
did you have anything to share
oh yeah i i think that's a great
question it's still something that i'm
trying to improve uh so i wouldn't say
it's uh maybe it's not good
recommendation
but uh just so what i do now what we do
now is uh
we try to
i i feel the onboarding the way i think
about that is almost like you're
training
you're offering a specific training
for people to let's just say to get
better and then to
get to get them prepared for the the
work uh
and then the working culture the
legislative the uh institutional
knowledge all of that and setting up the
them for success for those tools
and then uh
in general we would have let's say like
uh like a guideline almost like a
training guide you have the agenda for
hey this is what what we want you to go
through for the first let's just say one
month
and then uh and a lot of times we use
the let's just say videos and then we
will have the impersonal training online
with different folks that touches
different uh ideas touches different
subjects
but i guess specifically for data
scientists or data analytics roles what
i have found helpful or i think one of
the keys
i want to get them up to speed is
analytical project
and
those type of things are usually deeply
connected with the business needs so
this is something that usually i would
just start with a high level business
goals and making sure the business goal
clicks first
so uh so you know let's just say if this
is for
a uh let's just say specific project
we're working on then i want to first go
over
how
this report how this process will help
us
to or help another team to get like to
say more accurate result more let's say
more effective approach to deal with
let's just say to make a better product
and then i will go over the legislative
high level process of what individual
staff will we will need to go through
so uh to usually the tasks that we were
going to first hand off are the ones
that everybody can click and run
so we're trying to minimize their
learning gap and then not trying to
intimidate people
uh
intimidate people of oh there are so
many things i need to learn no we're
going to give you that a
quick success feeling first it's almost
like you know getting people trained up
with r right i want you to feel the
power of click and run this is great i
helped solve the business problem that
tiger just mentioned to me an hour ago
and then lastly i would go over the
difficult part that we face in this uh
in this process
so those are the ones maybe tricky part
for example if we're uh if this is a
shiny app we're supporting them i would
go over some of the last common things
that uh
we would use or more difficult which is
the more complicated uh setup that we
have
for example if this analyst does not uh
is not familiar with the let's just say
future promises then it's a good idea uh
for for us to be prepared to share that
maybe as a last step of handing off that
project to them
uh so
typically onboarding that's what i would
follow is minimize the let's just say
don't get them don't intimidate them and
just start with the
why we are doing things and then we
offer let's just say the quick success
feeling feeling everybody is you know uh
feels great about this process lastly we
went over the harder ones
so later on let's just say the next
iteration
people will feel oh
uh
i know exactly why i'm doing this i know
how to do it so that's the second step
and lastly
in case there's any difficult questions
i can reach out to tiger or i can you
know figure it out based on the
information tiger shared or other team
members here so i would say that's my
high level idea for onboarding
thank you tiger that actually sounds a
lot like getting executive buy-in or
business partner buy-in really
offer quick wins build trust and then
move into things that are more difficult
or more complex i think that's fantastic
i've never heard it described that way
oh i appreciate it
yeah i guess uh uh i kind of feel like
in the end we're uh
we're just working with uh people right
right yeah either way it's people
yeah we're trying to make uh all the
experience smoother uh and i guess we oh
it all comes down to us to bear all of
these uh uh let's say ideas you know you
know all mine
so people working around us uh they're
let's just say receiving the uh good
experience there
love that advice i see brittany you have
your hand raised too do you want to jump
in
yeah when i heard onboarding my mind
literally started like flying off in
fireworks um at least at my company we
over years have tried to refine our
onboarding process constantly and one
thing that we found is actually using
um
like making sure that your onboarding is
really really well documented and then
knowing who is responsible for what in
terms of onboarding so whenever we
onboard a new team member
they typically have a mentor that will
be their mentor for at least the first
six months probably the first year that
they're with the company and then they
have their team leader
and their specific task that we've
actually assigned out to the mentors and
the team leaders
um and
one of the things you brought up too is
making sure that that new team member
has a focus and has ownership something
that they can really like
run with and provide value with and
we've actually used a microsoft planner
to like literally lay out almost like an
asana type board where there's tasks
assigned to each person and
like all of the nitty-gritty things from
like hr onboarding all the way through
like
reflection after the first 90 days it's
all kind of laid out there so i think
it's also good just to really like even
if it's as simple as just post-it notes
on a whiteboard really understanding all
of the different things that someone has
to do when they onboard and then making
that plain and available for them
especially you make sure there's no
gaps are things that you miss when
you're onboarding people and maybe on
person a got you know xyz when they
onboard it but they missed abc
and things like that so we just found
that like having something like that set
up and then just making copies for each
new person we on board was really really
helpful
i'm curious for
both of you and and whoever wants to
jump in uh colin from our studio and i
were chatting about this with
onboarding how do you also ensure
that you share the team culture right
from the start or the company culture
when people are going through like so
many like checklists of these are the
things that i have to go through
yeah so from from uh i think just now i
i heard great advice and then i i really
like the uh let's just say i think
everybody's uh prefer the visual type of
uh
layout and i think that's yeah that's
something i'm definitely going to check
out uh
and then
let's say from from my side and then uh
we
uh
well we bundled that task let's just say
we we work together uh with hr team on
that to make work fun and then so that's
how one of the things that we promote
and then we also have like so
we would kind of share that task and
then so hr team will uh
organize the uh let's just say since
most people are online now at the online
events and then uh to trying to have
that uh let's just say
uh
a different experience outside of the
zoom meeting uh type of uh work
and then um
and i guess the other one is that we
also sometimes it's the co i think the
company culture type of thing is
something
uh i also try to uh try a lot of
different ways and then try to say oh
this is how i experience i want you to
feel maybe similarly
but then i realized that i have a
several years of staying in this company
so it's something that i think later on
uh i realized it's something that maybe
we'll just uh from time to time let the
people experience that uh just give it
more time so we will share the
there's a high level but
in the end i will always say or share
that it's something that you will have
the firsthand experience yourself
so uh i would find opportunity for them
to connect with other team members
uh
in person if there is opportunity
uh but if not and then uh we will just
try to uh i think you know connect with
people online with different zoom
activities i think there is a different
vendors for that type of activity as
well
um alan i'm sorry i realized i missed
your question earlier um do you want to
jump in and ask that one
yeah um and no worries there this is the
classic like i have to ask a question
and then go to my next um like far less
interesting
meetings at the top of the hour but i'm
curious tiger if your team ends up in a
situation where you build these really
like interesting develop and exciting
tools that provide lots of value for
folks and then end up needing to sort of
support and own it for the long term and
if you're faced with a dilemma of how do
we
you know provide that support while
continuing to give like meaningful
interesting new work to the folks on the
team um for for me that's a dilemma of
figuring out you know how do we maintain
stuff and also continue to develop um
and so i wonder if you've got a good a
good solution there
yeah uh i want this a great question so
i uh well luckily i think uh yeah we
still need to do that as well so it's
the same issue that we're facing here uh
so luckily i guess the maintenance work
uh
is probably uh of the let's just say
maybe
five to ten percent portions it's a very
small portion we don't we haven't
got to the stage where we have to impact
our which is a regular bigger project
but one of the things i think
we are trying to follow uh in the past
is that
it is just to just maintenance work
that will have this for example
application to keep functioning we will
definitely take care of it uh right away
you know as soon as we can
uh but if it has new additional features
we will
uh treat that as additional uh just
brand new work we wouldn't consider that
as something that oh we feel obliged to
uh to work on that you know before any
of the other bigger projects
uh we try to follow through the uh the
prioritization process that uh mentioned
earlier is that uh for that type of work
uh we will
treat it as a brand new thing and then
we will try to evaluate to say
you uh with this enhancement feature
versus another brand new app which one
does the stakeholder want earlier
so uh so i think we will if this one
indeed has more business value
uh then we'll work on that first so in
the end
we will let the business side to decide
which one has more value so but using
that uh
having that it did save us uh let's say
save us from some of those dilemmas
where we feel really obliged to
enhance that feature
but then we don't really want to delay
another nexus citing a project so once
we have followed this prioritization
method i think everybody feels better
uh of how
because we are following a subsidiary
process here we're not trying it is not
me or the team member saying that this
is something i don't want to work on
uh so i hope i hope that helps a little
bit
yeah for sure it does really appreciate
that that distinction and i think
establishing that expectation that we
will need to do that kind of
prioritization and life cycle thinking
with stakeholders is really important so
i think it's a good market success that
you're able to do that and say like you
know there's a maintenance category and
there's a new work category and we need
you know stakeholders help to help
navigate and steer those things
so yeah really really appreciate it
thanks um great great conversation
thanks everybody
thank you and i
i feel like the hour went by even
quicker today than it normally does so i
know we're a few minutes over
and a few people have to go run to
meetings and tiger i
think you might have to go run to a
meeting as well
but thank you so much for for sharing
your experience with us
if people do want to stay on and chat
i'll keep the bridge open i think there
may be were a few questions i didn't get
to um
but tiger really appreciate your time if
people have follow up is the best place
to connect with you linkedin or
or twitter which you prefer
oh yeah linkedin or twitter okay
okay awesome and uh
we can share that in the chat here
as well
awesome well thank you so much
have a great rest of the day everybody
you